so this talk could be a little
challenging because we're gonna see some
stuff that tickles our brains and some
images that will be a little disturbing
although it won't really be clear why
they're disturbing and we'll talk about
why and we'll talk about some things
that we don't usually talk about and all
sorts of stuff sort of pours out when
you open walks like that and so if you
can be here for it I would love that
and if you can't take care of yourself
otherwise hello my name is Oishi and as
Brandon mentioned I am a senior software
engineer at github and that really has
nothing whatsoever to do with the talk
that you're about to hear because today
I want to talk to you about a hobby I'd
like to share some of what I've learned
at the intersection of computational
neuroscience and artificial intelligence
for years I've been fascinated by how we
think how we perceive how the
machineries of our bodies creates
subjective experience and why our
experiences are shaped in the way they
are why we feel joy and why we suffer
and for years I've been fascinated by
machine learning and AI and I think we
all have we're watching these little
machines begin to approximate the tasks
of computer of cognition and sometimes
unsettling ways and so today I want to
share some of what I've learned some of
it is solid research some of it is solid
speculation and all if it speaks to a
truth that I have come to believe which
is that we are computations our worlds
created on an ancient computer powerful
beyond imagining so let's begin part
mutten hallucinations this person is
Mikkel perio Nieto and he has something
to show us
it starts with simple patterns these
splotches of light and dark like images
from the first eyes these then give way
to lions and colors and then curves and
more complex shapes
we're diving through the layers of the
inception image classifier and it seems
that there are whole worlds in here
shaded multi traumatic hatches the
crystalline form fields of alien worlds
cells of plants to understand where
these visuals are coming from let's look
inside
the job of an image classifier is to
reshape its input which is a square of
pixels into its output which is a
probability distribution the probability
that the image contains the cat the
probability of a dog a banana a toaster
it performs this reshaping through a
series of convolutional filters
convolutional filters are a lot like
Photoshop filters each neuron in a
convolutional layer has a receptive
field a small patch of the previous
layer of neurons from which it's taking
its input each convolutional layer
applies the filter specifically it
applies an image kernel a matrix where
each number represents the weight of a
corresponding input neuron so each pixel
in a neurons receptive field is
multiplied by the weight and then we
summed them all to get this neurons
output value we apply the same filter
across a layer and those values are
learned during training so we feed the
classifier labelled image that outputs
predictions we math to figure out how
wrong those predictions are then we math
again nudging each and every single
filter in the direction that would have
produced a better result so that's a
gradient descent the deep dream process
inverts this so this visualization is
recursive to compute the next frame we
feed the current frame into the network
we start with that photo if Michela we
then run that image through the networks
many layers until we activate the layer
that we're interested in and then we
math how could we adjust the input image
to make this layer activate more and
then we adjust the image in that
direction so this process is gradient
ascent finally we scale the image up
slightly before feeding it back into the
network this keeps the
us from fixating on local features and
it also creates this pretty wild zooming
effect every 100 frames or so we moved
to deeper layer or a layer to the side
inception has a lot of layers and
they're not arranged in a linear stack
and that gives us this we started with
these rudiments of light and shadow and
then much deeper we have this city of
kodamas situation happening shortly
we're gonna enter the spider observation
zone in which spiders observe you but
it's okay because the spiders will
quickly become corgis and the corgis are
going to become the 70s deeper we find a
space of nearly human eyes which are
going to become dogs dogs slug birds
here I found a sort of unfortunate
saxophonist teleporter accident and
finally near the end we have the flesh
zones with a side of lizard and okay
when I first saw this I was reminded of
nothing so much as Donald Trump and I
never say that out loud in public until
I showed this to my best friend who said
exactly the same thing and I think this
says more about the state of our neural
networks what we are primed to see than
this one but I do want you to notice and
think about what it means that all this
skin is so very white so all of this is
pretty trippy why is that what does that
mean for something to be trippy so to
figure that out
let's take a look inside ourselves meet
Scully Scully doesn't need all this
craft we are just here to look at Scott
Scully's visual system which starts here
in the retina so Scully is retina your
retinas are retinas they're weird light
comes into them and it immediately hits
this membrane there's a layer of
ganglions which we'll get back to late
ganglions are not particularly
photoresist photosensitive but they are
the first layer of things that light
coming into your retina hits there's a
layer of more stuff but does important
things and then at the back of your
retina or the photoreceptors rods and
cones so light comes in winds its way
through four layers of tissue to its
ganglion or and and hits a photoreceptor
and then that photoreceptor gets excited
it sends out a signal to its ganglions
which then send it somewhere where to an
optic nerve that we've drilled right
through the center of the eye so our
sensors are mounted backwards and
there's a hole in the center of them and
it's all kind of okay because we can
patch up the issues in software but
there's a couple of other problems one
our retinas have a hundred and twenty
six million photoreceptors give or take
that's 120 million rods which sends
luminance and six million cones sensing
color and there's about ten times fewer
ganglions than that to the optic nerve
has about ten megabits of bandwidth just
not really enough we're trying to send
this the signal from this 126 megapixel
camera through a pipe but slower than
Wi-Fi and so our retinas do what you
might do if faced with that problem they
compress the data
so each ganglion connects to a patch of
about a hundred photoreceptor cells
which is its receptive field let's
divide it into a central disc and the
surrounding region and when there's no
light on any of it the game Leon doesn't
fire when the whole field is illuminated
it starts to fire weakly and now you're
ganglions come in two species they're
not actually two species they're the
same cell behaving in slightly different
ways one kind of ganglion when the
surround is illuminated and the center
is dark about half of half of your
ganglions are going to fire rapidly the
other half aren't going to fire at all
and then the other half of ganglions
behave exactly in the opposite way
they fire weekly when their centerfield
is illuminated or they only fire when
their Center is illuminated and their
surround to Stark and so taken together
you sort of think about it it makes
sense this constitutes an edge detection
filter we're doing this processing even
in our eyeballs and it's quite important
this processing lets us down sample the
signal from our photoreceptors a hundred
times while retaining vitally important
information namely where the edges of
objects might be so then the signal goes
through the brain it hits the optic
chiasma where the data streams from
where left and right eyes cross which
gives us 3d stereo vision it's processed
by the thalamus which amongst other
things is responsible for running your
eyes autofocus something that you
definitely have and maybe weren't
thinking about it up until now it also
integrates with various others and
sensory inputs from different modalities
so each step of the signal pathway is
performing a little bit of signal
processing extracting a little bit of
information from the signal and all of
that is before we get the big visual
processing center the visual cortex all
the way around back here so our visual
cortex is arranged into a stack of
neuronal layers the signal stays
relatively spatially oriented through
the visual cortex so there's some slice
of tissue in the back of your brain that
is responsible for pulling faces out of
this particular chunk of your visual
field more or less brains are a little
bit messy so each neuron in a layer has
a receptive field just some chunk of the
entire visual field that it's looking at
neurons in a given layer respond in the
same way to signals within their
receptive field and that operation
distributed over an entire layer of
neurons extract some feature from the
signal first simple features like lions
and curves and edges and then more
complex ones like gradients and surfaces
objects eyes faces motion it's no
accident that we see the same behavior
in Inception
because convolutional neural networks
were inspired by the structure of our
visual cortex of course our visual
cortex is different from inception in
many ways inception is a straight shot
through its one pass from input to
output our visual cortex contains a lot
of feedback loops these pyramidal
neurons that connect deeper layers to
earlier ones these loops allow the
results of deeper layers to inform the
behavior of previous layers so for
example we might turn up the edge
detection game where a later layer
detected an object this lets our visual
system adapt and focus not optically but
attentionally it gives us the ability to
ruminate on visual input even before we
become consciously aware of it improving
our predictions over time and I think
you know this feeling thinking you see
one thing and then realizing it's
something else
so these loopback pyramidal cells in our
visual cortex are covered in serotonin
receptors and different kinds of
pyramidal cells respond to serotonin
differently but generally they find it
exciting and don't we all you might be
familiar with serotonin from its
starring role as the target of typical
antidepressants which are generally
serotonin reuptake inhibitors when
serotonin gets released into the brain
they make it stick around longer thereby
treating depression some side effects
may occur most serotonin is actually
located in your gut where it controls
bowel movement its signals to your gut
that it's got food in it and should go
on and do what it does to food and that
seems to be with the molecule signals
throughout your body resource
availability and for M animals with
complex societies like ours those
resources can be somewhat more abstract
social resources as well as energetic
ones that your pyramidal cells respond
excitedly to serotonin suggests that we
focus on that which we believe will
nourish us so it's not correct as a
blanket statement to say that pyramidal
cells are it
cited by serotonin in fact there's
different kinds of serotonin receptors
and they're binding produces different
effects so five ht1 a receptors tend
actually to be inhibitory 5h d3
receptors are somewhat odd in the brain
they're associated with sensations of
queasiness and anxiety in the gut they
make it run backwards anti-nausea drugs
are frequently 5-ht three antagonists
there's another kind of serotonin
receptor one that the pyramidal cells of
your brain find particularly exciting
this is the 5ht 2a receptor it's the
primary target for every known
psychedelic drug it is what enables our
brains to create psychedelic experiences
so you go to a show and you eat a little
piece of paper and that piece of paper
makes its way down into your stomach
where it dissolves releasing molecules
of LSD into your gut now LSD does not
bind to 5h t3 receptors so if you're
feeling butterflies in your stomach it's
just because you're excited for what's
going to happen and what's going to
happen is this the lysergic acid
diethylamide will diffuse into your
blood LSD has no trouble crossing the
blood-brain barrier because it's tiny
but powerful like you it will diffuse
deep into your brain into a visual
cortex where it finds the pyramidal 5-ht
to a receptor and locks into place the
molecule stays bound for around 221
minutes
it's four hours which is a very long
time for receptor binding they think
that a couple of proteins sort of get
attracted and lock into place forming a
lid over top of the receptor trapping
the LSD inside which would help explain
why it's so very potent with typical
doses about a thousand times less than
most other drugs so while it's rattling
around in there the little LSD molecule
is stimulating a feedback loop in your
visual cortex it's sending a signal that
says pay attention what you're looking
at may be nourishing it might be
important and so the pattern finding
machinery on your cortex starts to run
over time and at different rates in
moment the pattern in a tapestry seems
to extend into the world beyond it in
the next there it's the trees that are
growing and breathing the movement of
visual perception that's been allowed to
grow wild with deep dream we asked what
would excite some layer of Inception and
then we adjusted the input image in that
direction now there's no comparable
gradient ascent process in the
biological psychedelic experience and
that's because we aren't looking at a
source image we're looking at the output
of the network
we we are the output of the network the
output of your visual cortex is a signal
carrying visual perceptions kind of
proto qualia which are going to be
integrated by other circuits in your
brain to produce your next moment of
experience now inception never gets that
far we never even run it all the way to
the classification stage we never ask it
what it sees in all this but we could in
fact we could perform the amplification
process on a final result rather than an
intermediate one maybe we ask what would
it take for you to see this banana as a
toaster or stay with me don't these
skiers look like a dog so these are
adversarial examples images that have
been tuned to give classifiers Frank
hallucinations the confident belief that
they're seeing something that just isn't
there and they're not completely wild
these robot delusions I mean that
sticker really does look quite a lot
like a toaster and it's very shiny and
those two skiers kind I mean they're
four legs which is doglike and you can
kind of see the head on the left and
like the tail on the right and okay it's
like it's very dodgy a person might
looking at them they might look at them
and see if they're very tired and far
away and drunk for a second they might
think that they're looking at a big dog
maybe but they definitely wouldn't
conclude that it's a big dog
because there were current properties of
our visual cortex and not to mention
much of the rest of our brain means that
our sense of the world is stateful it's
a continuously refined hypothesis whose
state is held by the state of our
neurons
Lisa sabor preparing us for capsule
networks writes that a parse tree is
carved out of them fixed multi-layer
neural network like a sculpture is
carved from rock so our perceptions here
are a process of continuous refinement
which may point the way towards more
robust recognition architectures
recurrent convolutional neural networks
that ruminate upon images making better
classifications or providing a signal
that something is off about an input
there are adversarial examples for the
human visual system after all and we
call them optical illusions and they
feel very weird to look at like in this
image we can feel our sensory
interpretation of the scene flipping
between three alternatives a little box
in front of the big one a box in a
corner and a box missing one and then in
this munkar illusion
there is something scintillating about
the colors of the dots which are of
course all the same if we design
convolutional neural networks with their
currents they could exhibit such
behavior as well which maybe doesn't
sound so great like let's make our image
classifiers vacillating and uncertain
but it's our ability to hem and haw and
reconsider our own perceptions of many
levels that gives our perceptual system
tremendous robustness paradoxically
being able to second-guess ourselves
allows us greater confidence in our
predictions we're doing science in every
moment the cells of our brain
continuously reconsidering and refining
shifting hypotheses about the state of
the world which gives us the incredible
ability to adapt and operate within an
extreme range of conditions even while
we're tripping face or well asleep
- dreams
these are not real people these are the
photos of fake celebrities which have
been dreamt up by a generative
adversarial Network a pair of networks
that are particularly creative the
networks get better through continuous
mutual refinement and it works like this
on the one side we have the creator this
is a deep learning network not unlike
inception but trained to run in Reverse
this network we feed with noise
literally it's a bunch of random numbers
and it learns to generate images from
that but it has no way to learn how to
play that game it doesn't know what a
plausible image looks like it lacks a
gradient without another network without
an opponent the adversary so the
adversary is also an image classifier
like inception but it's trained on only
two classes real and fake and its job is
to distinguish the creator's forgeries
from true faces so we feed this network
with ground truth we train it on actual
examples of celebrity faces and the
adversary learns and then we use those
results to train the creator if it makes
a satisfying forgery that passes through
the adversary then it's doing well if
it's forgeries are detected then we back
propagate that failure so that it may
learn now I should tell you that the
technical names for these networks are
the generator and the discriminator I
changed the names because names are
important and powerful and also
meaningless
they don't change the structure of the
training methodology which is incredibly
powerful a semi-supervised learning
technique we haven't gone and taken a
huge data set of possible generated
images and labeled them as plausible and
implausible no that would be an
impossible task instead we have this
process of recursive code training where
two circuits are playing a game
ruminating on a space of possibilities
and so extracting maximum value from a
small amount of training data this
process is perhaps helpful for neural
circuits of all kinds
though it does have a few quirks ganzar
not so great at global structure this is
this is fall out cow here it's grown a
cow with an extra body just as you may
have spent a night walking through a
house that is your house but with many
extra rooms and the networks are not
particularly great at counting either
accounting being a reduce operation you
can kind of imagine why they are not
great at it
here we have a monkey with a ties
because sometimes science goes too far
and do something for me next time you
think you're awake which i think is now
presumably count your fingers just to be
sure and if you find right now that you
have more or fewer than you expected
don't make up just yet because we're not
quite done so another interesting thing
about this training methodology is that
the generator is being fed noise a
vector of noise some random point in a
very high dimensional space and so it
learns a mapping between that space and
its generation target in this case faces
and so if we take a point in that space
and we drag it around we get this which
is also pretty trippy it resembles
things that I've seen that someone who
isn't me has seen on acid it resembles
the sorts of things that you may have
seen in long-forgotten dreams and I do
not have a Magic School Bus riot to take
us on to understand why that is but I do
have a theory and that theory is when we
see a face a bunch of neurons in our
brain light up and begin resonating a
signal which is the feeling of looking
at that particular face taken together
all of the neurons that participate in
face detection produce a vector
embedding a mapping from faces to
positions in some high dimensional face
space and as we drag around the
generators vector here so too are we
dragging around our own which is a novel
and somewhat unsettling sensation
so that's a wild theory but it's not
without neurocognitive precedent so here
we have a rat and a cage
we've hooked an electrode up to a
particular region a particular neuron in
the rat's brain and those pink dots are
the locations where it's firing so if we
speed this up a pattern is going to
start to emerge
that neuron is a grid cell so named
because the Centers of its firing fields
produce a triangular grid now there's a
lot of different grid cells in your
brain each own lining to a slightly
different grid they collect data from
your visual system and from head
Direction cells which similarly encode a
quaternion
from your for your head and together
they construct an encoding of our
position in 2d Euclidean space this
operates even in our sleep if earlier
you discover that you're dreaming and
you want to see this end of end of this
talk but you're having trouble staying
asleep an aeronaut since people who
specialize in lucid dreaming recommends
spinning around this detaches you're
perceived body the one with 12 fingers
and three extra bedrooms from your
physical body which is lying asleep in
bed right now so this positioning system
is something which on some level you
always knew existed after all you have a
sense of space as you move through it
you know where you are and it's likely
even necessary if we believe that
cognition is computation that our
qualitative sense of position has a
neurocognitive precursor a signal in the
web that tells us where we're at in many
senses of the word
part three sticks and stones and they
say you can't tickle yourself because
you know it's coming
specifically when your brain sends an
action command to your muscles
that's called an efference when an
efference is sent your brain makes a
copy and it makes a copy sounds so plan
so engineered your brain is this big
messy evolved signal processing mesh and
so another way of thing to think of
efference copies is as reflections so we
take the efference and we send it out to
our peripheral nerves where presumably
it's going to make some muscles contract
meanwhile from the efference copy we
predict how our body's state will change
and we use that to update our brains
model of our body's state now if we
didn't do this then we would have to
wait for sensory data to come back from
our peripheral neurons to tell us what
happened like where is our hand right
now and then we would face the same
problem as trying to play a twitchy
video game over a crap connection
signals take about 10 milliseconds to go
from our brain to our periphery and
another 10 milliseconds to travel back
our body our nervous system it's not
that low latency and so to enable smooth
coordinated movements our brain has to
make predictions so let goes on but in a
moment we have a problem because we will
still receive sense data from our nerves
if we updated our models again they
would actually fall out of sync this is
the like double applied server report
problem solving it between a client and
server we might tag the data somehow but
our brain doesn't really have a unique
ID counter so the model is more complex
but it does result in the signal being
attenuated which keeps our model in sync
so this attenuation applies to our sense
of touch as well when that touch is an
expected consequence of our own movement
so this is clearly quite a complex model
and aspects of it are lightly
distributed throughout the brain but
there's one place that's particularly
important in maintained
and executing it the cerebellum the
cerebellum is quite special
it contains half the neurons in our
nervous system all action commands from
the brain to the body route through it
and all sensations from the body to the
brain as well it's long been recognized
as vitally important to motor
coordination like this people with
cerebellar damage have difficulty
performing this action smoothly with
cerebellar damage our movements become
jerky laggy it's been theorized that the
cerebellum acts as a Smith predictor our
brains controller for latency distant
bodies able to estimate the body's
current state integrate sensory feedback
to update that model and decompose gross
actions generated elsewhere in our brain
into a fine-tuned continuously adjusted
control signal and once you've evolved
it such a thing has many uses there's a
growing body of evidence implicating the
cerebellum in language which does make
sense uh pterence is a kind of movement
and language she said gesticulating
wildly is not limited to utterance the
work of moving words is not so different
from the work of moving the body
they are both transformations from the
space of internal states afferents and
ideas to the space of world coordinates
and external sense impressions and other
people and back again and what happens
when this predictor encounters a problem
oh I just realized I need sound this is
gonna happen I can do this so what
happens when this petite predictor
encounters a problem when there's an
irreconcilable discontinuity in the
model
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so these things are not so different
we're both very visceral actions they're
guttural they shake our bones and jokes
similarly are shaped like trauma
they're both shatter atoms the
Illuminations of discontinuities they're
paradoxes things which cannot be and yet
are things which we must revisit again
and again churning water smoothing the
edges of cutting stone the machinery of
our brains trying to make sense of a
world that resists it so preparing this
talk has been a kind of difficult time
for me I didn't think I could do it the
world seems to be falling apart I got
dumped which didn't help there were days
when I would open my email and every
subject line would be a stone and I
would think to put them on to my address
and weigh it out into the sea but I
didn't because I remembered that I am
process of creation I am a song singing
myself
we are stories telling ourselves a sea
understanding itself our returning waves
create every exquisite moment of joy and
agony and everything else it's you it's
all you you are everything everything
you have ever seen every place you have
ever been every song you have ever sung
every god you have ever prayed to every
person you have ever loved the
boundaries between them and you and the
sea and the stars are all in your
thank you that's all
Oh now it comes out well if there are no
more questions we can think gosh thank
you everyone you feel free to reach out
to me on Twitter if you do you have any
questions what do you use to create
these lines that's that is actually the
most common question JavaScript but the
web I use the web it's a website
yeah here's Chrome so all those web
technologies yeah a lot of CSS actually
Hayashi hi thank you so much for an
incredible talk thank you
what what is the next step how do we
take another step closer between
reconciling biological computation and
where we are in be a deep learning or
electronic computation I think we're
taking a lot of the next steps right now
so there are projects to simulate parts
of the brain and there's there's a
project I think a sub-project of the
connectome research group which is which
has simulated like a tiny chunk of a rat
brain and all of these simulations are
it's a little bit hard right because we
actually can't measure
actual data to know how good the
simulation is and so you have to kind of
figure out proxies to evaluate your
models but more of that kind of work I
think I think that kind of work is one
Avenue and then getting better imaging
technology is another and I think we
have OK access through F MRIs a lot of
that data is like really heavily
massaged and it's it's like quite hard
because you have a very thick skull
that's the problem we have thick skulls
but I have a suspicion that in the next
like in the next 20 years the time
horizon that makes anything possible in
futurism we're going to see like really
significant advances in nanotechnology
that'll make that kind of imaging better
like you can imagine really smart dyes
that can sort of outlined an externally
presented magnetic field and give us a
lot of insight into when neurons are
firing when membranes are depolarizing
and that's going to be the other avenue
that I think really blows it open so the
biggest difference between the machine
and a computer is that human could do
causal analysis so there's been work
done on causal inference as well for
machines this is one route that you'd
think would work out and to get machines
to do causal inference yes I think well
maybe I don't understand that problem
space very well but I think one thing
that separates our the machinery of our
experience from most of these machine
learning systems is that we are deeply
deeply recurrent like our parts of our
brain are wired and loops all over the
place which is why we have sort of a
continuous experience like why one
moment like leads to the next moment and
we haven't I think even really tried to
do that in machine learning models and
part because recurrent models are
famously hard to train I'm sure there's
techniques for that are improving all
the time but we have a lot of training
data play
hundreds of millions of terabytes of
input data from a robot walking around
in a world and then also all this like
social queuing and so just getting the
amount of training data required to
train sort of a recurrent system like
our brains that can do the kinds of
causal analysis that our brains can do
which if you think about it is sort of
it comes out of having a narrative
structure like I kind of exist because
my brain is trying to figure out why my
body is doing all these things and it's
like oh I must I must be an agent with
moral responsibility so yeah I think we
can get there but I think we need it we
need like another order of magnitude of
training data and probably better
techniques hi thanks for your talk I
like the floor of the framework you used
my question is about what you think
about the consistency of consistency of
interpretation that you would expect
from people when they look at the
outputs of a model or something like
that like we try to build a lot of
models that we expect will do certain
things but I think there's a lot of
variability in terms of how people will
look at those results whether it's a
customer whether it's internally and so
have you thought about that concept in
general like the variability of how the
brain parses the outputs of some of
these things and whether you can design
a model that would be consistently
interpreted by everybody or whether
there's always going to be debate that's
really interesting so in in this case
here you're sort of asking about I'm the
people if we're looking at the results
of some statistical model will interpret
it and they bring their own biases right
there's another active modeling
basically and can we train a model too
and that this is where I'm not clear can
we train a model to do what to produce a
certain internal representation within
the people who read it basically yeah
like you know can you
can you account for that or you
basically you have no control over that
second process and so you're always
going to have like you contribute half
of the equation and the recipient
contributes the other half I mean it's
really fascinating I think you can you
just have to include that in your
training paradigm like you could imagine
a system where you you don't produce
your MA the output of your model or the
feedback criteria if your model is
actually like what action do people
looking at the report think is right and
it would be interesting to get training
data for that you could maybe imagine
getting Trina training data for that
just by doing some kind of historical
analysis so you take I don't know stock
data and you're like by showing this
screen to a human the human should make
the right decisions and you know what
those decisions should have been and so
the new train a model to basically
manipulate whoever is looking at it I
think you should ask Facebook about this
they seem to be really really at least
they seem to be good at that
or they seem to be working on it what
about a machine that can think about
questions to ask by itself and query the
world for questions that needs to answer
to get a better prediction like it were
ask the question not the human yes so
this would be something like determining
that there's really high it basically
doesn't the current model doesn't have
enough resolving power along some
dimension it and it knows what it wants
to get that resolved and resolution and
yes something we don't have much of it
all is sort of hierarchical machine
learning systems I I think I'm sure
someone's doing research into this but
where where it can sort of decompose
problems that subproblem it can
decompose a large-scale goal into
subproblems we are mostly doing that
kind of architectural work now in like
by hand and how
architect these systems I they're the
only thing I can think of is that there
was a recent paper from Google where
they had some they had some model
construct a different model to or like
optimize a different model for a problem
and so I think that's perhaps the tip of
that iceberg but yeah hugely unexplored
ok great thank you everybody that's all
the time we have for questions let's
think Joshi again thanks everyone
[Applause]